you know all those ted-ed videos you
love the beautiful animations that help
you learn new things that experience is
free for you but it's really expensive
for us and that's okay
our mission is to invest in thoughtful
people but we need some of you to invest
in us why because the love you've shown
ted-ed has already empowered millions of
young people around the world and if you
couple that love with a small monthly
donation on patreon the ted-ed
experience could empower billions if I
could describe the ted-ed experience in
one word exhilarating innovating
curiosity worthwhile inspiring I open an
illness technically but one word if you
put - I open ted-ed animations which are
written by educators are already being
viewed by over two million learners a
day when I came across ted-ed
it was like this is it this works with
your support we could engage more
animators to work with more teachers and
we'd be able to dub our content into
multiple languages my mind just went
right when I saw it
we'd also use your investment to grow
our student voice program ted-ed clubs
which teaches students how to present
their ideas in the form of Ted style
talks thousands of clubs have formed in
over 120 countries help us invite a
generation of young people to Ted's
mainstage when you turn stuff over to
students we give them that agency and
authority it's so much better because
it's them
there's something for me to start if you
want to support young people you want to
support educators in your country this
is the sort of program well this is the
model and we really should all be
looking at when it comes to making that
change check out our patreon perks and
thanks for your support